[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ami de l'homme en noir
bienvenu dans happy hours et le canal
savoir
le premier jeu dansé sur le ring de ses
candidats les deux équipes qui vont
s'affronter
son la diva des mythes roselyne bachelot
est l'inventeur du cian healy tuque
[Applaudissements]
gablé star de danse avec les stars
sandrine quétier
il aura toutes les demi-heures
nazionale niort
ces deux équipes de personnalités bon
jouer sur le thème qu'elle préfère elle
même l'enjeu est simple l'équipe
gagnante aura le droit de faire plus de
promo que l'autre alors vous votre promo
c'est l'album du char oui oui c'est le
dl le dernier album déjà le 19e le chat
passe à table roselyne rendez vous sur
d8 tous les matins 10h45 au début
personne n'y croyait et maintenant ça
marche
cinquante villes actu le mag tous les
samedis 18h10 et mathieu madénian
qu'évidemment en tournée dans toute la
france je me reproduit aussi donc c'est
bien c'est pas un acte eu ça
je prêt à tout pour gagner prêt à tout
pour enfoncer les autres je suis très
mal à l'aise parce que l'année dernière
nous avons fait équipe mathieu et moi
même voilà et cette fois vous nous
mettez face à face c'est un couple
faisait cher bat vraiment ça m'a fait
bizarre de te voir avec une autre elle
vraiment je te vois euros désolé de
faire équipe avec ton ex
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le bio au quiz
le principe est très simple
chacun d'entre vous doit faire l'objet
de deux questions sur sa vie mais ce
sera à l'autre équipe de répondre un
point par bonnes réponses on commence
par la vie de roselyne bachelot sandrine
et mathieu oui c'est à vous de répondre
pendant toute sa carrière politique
roselyne s'est toujours distinguée par
son look inimitable
on se souvient des tailleur bleu ciel de
ces veste fuchsia et bien sûr de ces
fameux crocs roses pour lesquels j'avais
fait une publicité incroyable d'ailleurs
il ya un look vous ai testé un jour et
sur lequel nous aimerions revenir aux
roses line bachelot est elle apparue
coiffure en pétard charbon sur le visage
et cigare explosé à la bouche à
l'anniversaire surprise de steevy boulay
dans un épisode de nos chers voisins
un salon de farces et attrapes dont elle
était la marraine ou à une soirée
déguisée
chez les balkany je pense aussi que
c'est ça ouais alors
qu'on habillée comme ça chez les balkany
s'est pas d'aiguiser
leur contenu parce que c'est moi je
crois que c'est dans leur l'épisode de
nos chers voisins voir où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous jouiez la cousine de 1 ou 2 way
odieuse audi le gvt h les maires à oui
vraiment c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup ri alors dans le grand vide sur
d8 roselyne n'hésite pas à se lâcher lcc
au rap avec la fouine elle balance des
ta gueule à ferrari elle lit des
passages très chaud de 50 nuance degrés
mais c'est pas nouveau tout avait
commencé dès la première émission en
octobre 2012
a déclaré roselyne bachelot alors
qu'elle essayait des chaussures à très
hauts talons dans l'émission le grand
huit j'ai un peu l'air d'une girafe oui
j'ai un peu l'air d'une cruche
j'ai un peu l'air d'une ou j'ai un
peu l'air d'une kohn a poussé j'ai un
peu l'air d'une
gt2 en bon je m'en souviens très bien
alors je vais ajouter là c'est cru et là
c est tres roselyne ya un petit côté
elle seule oui parce que les chaussures
avec des clous en fer est
alors sans briller mathieu vous
continuez à jouer mais cette fois avec
la vie de philippe geluck
cela fait de nombreuses années que
philippe geluck est un belge exilé
fiscal en france
très bizarre et la france rend bien la
france achète ses albums on le fait
bosser dans les journaux on l'invite sur
les plateaux télé mais attention
philippe reste une véritable star dans
son pays natal
en 2008 fils et pier-luc a donné son nom
un petit aéroport
[Musique]
à une mst
à une école ou à une marque de litière
pour chat
après ce pour être drôle c'était c'est
l'école une école une école exactement
une
fille
c'est pas une école de coiffure non
c'est us c'est une école primaire et
c'est très touchant parce que chaque
année ils remettent un prix philippe
geluck à l'élève non pas le plus
méritant mais j'ai demandé que ce soit à
celui qui s'est montré le plus solidaire
à 124 dans l'année voilà
c'est moi à propos de philippe geluck
c'est que c'est un véritable casse cou
un jour il a déclaré on a parfois de la
chance dans son malheur moi par exemple
je me suis blessé avec une boîte de
sparadrap
j'ai dit ça oui oui
ah oui mais je comprends pourquoi j'ai
dit oui c'est parce que j'avais tout de
suite de quoi me voilà
on se console
comment philippe geluck sais-tu blessé
au poignet droit il y à quelques temps
mais sa vie sexuelle c'est son problème
en réparant sa roue de vélo en désossant
un boeuf en faisant trop de dédicaces ou
en s'abonnant à des plaisirs solide ce
n'était pas alors à temps alors attends
ce que moi je le connais j'ai vécu avec
lui trois ans
cyclisme oui mais oui
moi je suis avec c'est parce que le bât
bon ouais en réparant sa roue de vélo
moi je dis que c'est ça jean pierre bade
fort
c'était non
[Applaudissements]
c'étaient les plaisirs solitaires je ne
fais que du vélo d'appartement qui comme
vous le savez ne comporte pas de roue
dans roue c'est en faisant trop de
détails alors là c'est plus la paix
était l'année dernière j'ai sorti la
bible selon le chat et j'ai fait une
tournée j'ai fait 28 séances de
dédicaces et donc j'ai dessiné au moins
six mille fois le chat dans des bouquins
et je me suis pété une articulation
effet tendinite sérieusement c'est pas
le truc à parce que woody allen disait
que se masturber c'est faire l'amour
avec quelqu'un qu'on aime bien
[Applaudissements]
résultat chaud le futur mari
blessé à la main droite mais j'aime
beaucoup ma main gauche
alors 120 et mathieu faisait marquer
trois points c'est pas mal
oui trois points sur quatre est même pas
mal alors on continue avec la vie de
sandrine justement rosine et philippe
c'est désormais à vous de répondre
sandrine quétier et le rayon de soleil
de tf1 elle cartonne avec 50 et vince
ivz elle cartonne avec danse avec les
stars mais toutes ces émissions c'est
beaucoup de pression et parfois faut se
lâcher à quelle occasion
sandrine quétier se plaquent tels les
cheveux en arrière avant de mettre du
maquillage noir son visage et dans
philippe vestes et des buttes de motards
mme quand elle veut effrayer ses enfants
pour halloween quand elle rend
secrètement visite à françois hollande
quand la sq quand elle monte sur scène
avec son groupe de musique ou quand elle
anime des soirées sem chez nikos aliagas
ceni des lycées s'est pas bdc a signé
six enfants si j'avais de l'eau s'est
tenue le 10 ans et carnoules peu de gens
le savent mais sandrine quétier monte
sur scène avec un groupe de musique
bravo
ça fait de joker s'est récemment produit
oblige pas jouer quoi comme musique en
fait des mash up en fait reprises de
rock avec un maquillage alakis un petit
peu moi je chante mais on est là on est
à bath basse guitare batterie et on
chante du rock et voilà
c'est dans cette émission
avant d'être en duo avec nikos sandrine
faisais des émissions avec christophe
dechavanne les 100 plus grands avec 100
plus grands fous rires et 100 plus
grands coups de gueule les 100 plus
grand quoique de direct les bêtises et
politique bref un concept usé jusqu'à la
corde
parmi les 100 plus grands
quelle émission sandrine quétier
n'at-elle jamais présenté les 100 plus
grandes caf les 100 plus grandes perles
d'enfants les 100 plus grands délires de
stars ou les 100 plus grands d'armagh de
tf1 où repose son messie au hasard il
s'agit de la réponse d abord
parce qu il aurait fallu et émile ça
peut être pour le programme re termine
avec l'avis de mathieu madénian rire un
peu crispé
alors on termine avec l'avis de mathieu
roselyne et philippe j'ai toujours à
vous de répondre en 2011 mathieu a eu
des soucis avec le front national il
faut dire qu'il avait traité les
électeurs du front national de fils de
ouais je voulais m'excuser auprès
de toutes les que j'ai pu offenser
et ça les gars de la marine n'avait
vraiment pas apprécié absolument pas du
tout plein aujourd'hui c'est une affaire
classée par la justice a été condamné
pour injure publique
ouais ceci dit cette histoire vous fait
du tort pour jouer vos spectacles vous
voulez jouer sans parler des courriers
bizarres que vous recevez ouais c'est
bellemare qui me parle
là 8h30 il rentre chez lui il ouvre le
garage est là là encore il
ya un corps affreusement mutilés
suite à ses ennuis avec le front
national
mathieu madénian a eu la surprise de
trouver dans sa boîte aux lettres une
balle de revolver un petit cercueil une
tête de cochon mort ou une déclaration
d'amour d'arlette laguiller je crois que
c'est un petit cercueil
oui parce que d'éditer pas très grand
non plus donc un petit sursaut expirait
le cochon mort c'est fait c'est
compliqué de faire en train de nos
boîtes aux lettres ou me couper en
tranches comme les jambons 40 ans et
emploie passion et lu quelque part
le petit cercueil la réponse des gens
[Musique]
c'est une balle perdue ouais je vais
joueur bon oeil avec la balle il n'y
avait pas la remet donc c'est pas
dangereux papa de sauter dessus c'est
pas mais c'est assez bizarre oui
je laisse les prétendants l'approchait
le supplanter donc mathieu mais l'union
est ce qu'on appelle un tweet au cirque
il est accro à twitter et il n'hésite
pas à balancer les bonnes vannes à ses
followers
vous avez près de 70 mais je suis sûr
qu'après cette émission mathieu vous
sera 100 1000 followers
lequel de ces tweets n'est pas de
mathieu madénian et si on donnait le
corps de frigide barjot à la science
mais maintenant la la moitié des
français est tenté par le naturisme
n'essaie jamais la bonne moitié la sncf
est ses 75 ans et 45 ans en compte les
grèves
j'adore les enfants j'en ai plein mon
coffre
se lit
lequel n'est pas de mathieu madénian
maintenant j'ose plus lancé c'est drôle
ed c'est très drôle ah bon c'est très
belle maturité c'est drôle donc c'est
pas de lui maintenant aussi c'est de lui
lui avant le décès de luigi
d'autrui c'est horrible c'est drôle
c'est cet humour noir vous comprenez
c'est pas vrai il n'a pas vraiment
désormais complètement
encore oui c'est pas bien en inde aux
sections pauli alors je vous écoute je
laisse philippe moi je me suis planté la
dernière fois je laisse fini prendre sa
responsabilité en réalise y veut dire on
perd on a perdu un point fait de nous en
perdre de ces jeux
[Applaudissements]
avec des femmes cette école que je
savais quand même vous êtes parler un
type qui a donné son nom à une école
quand même alors
disons des bravos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors voilà à l'issue du bio crise on
est à égalité
yep à s'assécher
et a pris
un moment pour ne sais pas où tant de
plus de promo à la fin de l'émission le
suspense reste entier ou bien si
beaucoup d'ailleurs thierry je voulais
vous dire bon je sais que nous allons
gagner mais au cas où ça se passerait
autrement je voudrais dire que le chat
passe à table vient de sortir
[Rires]
son s'annulent vraiment honnêtement il
ya une règle du jeu c'est comme si moi
je parlais de ma tournée qu'elle se
prolonge en janvier février que j'allais
qui sort les choses
en plus d'une salle est restée sion je
ne dépends de noël aux radios je suis
aussi sur europe 1 et pas seulement sur
bwin monsieur t'ai entendu les gens ont
fait où tu peux nous dire où tu te
produira
attention on continue happy hour avec la
deuxième épreuve l'auto quiz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ikea simple chacun d'entre nous va voir
choix sont de seconde pour répondre à un
maximum de questions en rapport avec sa
vie chaque bonne réponse rapporte bien
sûr un point on va voir si vous vous
connaissez bien vous-même connais toi
toi même que naughty ses automnes
disaient les grecs voient la 10eme
ya un certain mais
roselyne c'est à vous de répondre en
premier attention
qui a dit vous
cette fille est capable de faire rougir
n'importe qui sarkozy qui a dit vous
roselyne bachelot représente pour moi la
quintessence de l'élégance et du chic à
la française
je ne sais pas personne
[Applaudissements]
c'est dégueulasse
c'est moi et moi qui les vit attention
pas quel était le nom de votre
pensionnat à angers alors sainte-agnès
pour cela ma retraite vous qui êtes
docteur en pharmacie qu'est nom
scientifique de l'aspirine l'acide
acétylsalicylique
ne fait pas les tenait ses informations
doit savoir ça si c'est pas ça c'est que
c'est juste votre dealer et qui connaît
rien aux autres produits
combien coûte une boîte de viagra agents
ne sait rien du tout fo demandé à
philips à
60 il fait de l'effet parlant commerce
oui je sais trois mois je n'ai pas
encore besoin
[Applaudissements]
à propos de qui avez vous déclaré il
vous prend par les couilles
sarkozy quand verdi à rouiba redis nous
prend par les coûts sont quand même
heureuse de quel homme politique
allez vous dit que c'était soit un
voleur soit un menteur claude guéant
sous quel nom est plus connue
laouni mouhid avec lequel je vais
chanter en duo sur le plateau du grand
huit la fouine la fouine bravo selon le
site pure médias quel est votre salaire
mensuel en tant que chroniqueuse
[Musique]
mise 5 hier ils sont heureux par
émission avait c'est bien c'est pas mal
c'est normal c'est une petit diène faye
lamballe je me dise que ça fait en boîte
de viagra
on continue avec vos filles allez-y
julien
de quelle couleur et la cravate que
porte votre chat sur la couverture du
dernier album rouge bravo qui vous a
remis le titre de commandeur de l'ordre
de la couronne
le roi albert ii sa majesté sa majesté
droit
dans quelle série télé avez vous joué un
rôle de présentateur une série télé
c'est sûr que c'est philippe en vendant
la dent dans la minute du chat temps
dans la minute du chat dans le bonheur
d'en face
ce repas attendait c'est qui c'est quoi
c'est sur quelle chaîne c'est une série
télé produit par qui en quelle année
c'est du bidon votre ami les réflexions
vous avez ce que j'ai demandé à dieu oui
seigneur tu la motta il dit que c'est
pas une vraie question est ce qu'on peut
lui donner au bois on voit son tir
merci seigneur si nous sommes que
quelques points
comment ce
qu'elle célèbre bataille a pris fin le
jour de votre naissance
vienne vienne fois vaut combien de pages
y at-il dans le coffret des deux volumes
le chat passe à table 192 bravo
il coûte combien ce coffret 17 euros 95
c'est moins cher ce serait du vol quelle
est la date de naissance officielle du
chat le 22 mars 83 trop froid en quel
journal le soir nasa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même temps
le score est remarquable en même temps
tu es ma vie quel est le prénom de votre
femme bravo
c'est pas comme m on récap des points
pour cette épreuve trois points pour
vous quel point fort c'est normal
j'attends encore joué la tension
sandrine quétier on passe à vous quel
cadeau avez vous fait à votre fille pour
son dixième anniversaire des black eyed
peas au stade de france brille avec qui
amy millet vous 10h le mag 7 heures lors
de l'émission star sous hypnose qu'avez
vous chanter alors que vous sembliez
complètement mort en quittant que mène
des rolling stones wild dans votre
entourage qui a déjà été stickers
official aux 24 heures du mans vincent
cerutti quel quotidien a publié un
article intitulé sandrine quétier la
chute et le parisien quel animateur a
dit de vous je suis totalement sous son
charme je suis foutu ça je sais pas
personne
c'est nikos en parlant de sa fille alors
qu'elle était votre prénom un série
jamais deux sans toi emma sophie se
retrouvent pas une équipe et dia il ya
une photo de vous prises à l'occasion de
l'avant première d'un film c'était quel
film vicky déficit était de tête et au
total nous de wall street pour vous
le réalisateur du good street les scores
faibles en europe
alors là c'est grave là le score est de
10 15 mathieu vous savez ce qu'il vous
reste à choisir
dans quelle ville avez vous joué
gratuitement au profit des restos du
coeur puget sur argens quelques uns sont
invités à vis de vous il se lâche
surprend et ça marche ma copine avant
avant l'acte un animateur de télévision
krucker drucker a cool quelle
personnalité a dit de vous mathieu je
veux rien savoir
tu es viré drucker
quel est le premier match que vous avez
vu au stade vélodrome
marseille rodez en 91 c'est ça combien
avez vous de critiques sur le site de
billetterie
billetreduc.com a amené à trouver le mec
qui regarde je sais pas en avoir à les
1000 milles 2206 2002 qu il regarde pas
mais c'est comme ça c'est ma mère qui me
tient au courant et data sans regarder
vous avez quoi dans votre poche droite
j'ai rien peut-être peut-être les 5
marathons j'ai peut-être les 50 euros
que je trouve plus dans mahler
non j'ai rien je crois que sur nous ce
soir en fait non j'ai pas d'argent non
geste ou d'un truc méline
ce
qu'il y a
je m'habille du pognon
ça arrive
si sa mère est une invention
tensions
sur page facebook quel est votre
employeur un truc al qaïda t'as qu'à un
qaïda région paca voilà combien coûte en
moyenne une passe au bois de boulogne
faut appeler mon père baba
et puis si je sais un visage chiffre 75
euros ça fait cinquante
[Applaudissements]
et voir deux gars montent et mathieu est
à 17 avec sandrine j'attaque tard
en or par exemple moi vous m'auriez
demandé ce que j'ai de ce que j'ai dans
la poche droite voilà regarder devant
vous j'aurais dit ça
non elle finit à tapis et lui ont
continué de la troisième épreuve le duo
pays
le principe est simple je vous lance une
affirmation et vous devez me dire lequel
des membres de l'autre équipe cela
concerne recommence avec vos usines et
philippe attention parmi vos adversaires
lequel des deux a déjà exercé le métier
d'avocat
alors à aa je sais pas je fais
le bitibak c'est quand même
pas que c'est parce que banide aucun de
mes jeux 100 m messieurs mathieu il a
été la fed a criminal il a un diplôme
d'avocat mais
c'est le piège vous êtes tombé dedans
elle résolument nul
dans les adversaires lequel des deux
mesure 1 m 74 propos à
8,74
lui doit ferment
m 57
et je suis que je suis debout la fois
qu'elle atteint 64 c'est vrai j'avais la
réponse est oui sans 3g sans bruit en
dix ans de repos mais penchant
pour les agresseurs
lequel des deux touchent régulièrement
des boules de loto
abbas et semble café présentez-nous taux
non plus que le nez c'est fait monsieur
loto cette semaine ouais elle touche les
boules de monsieur l'auto web là c'est
un air long des quais justifie qu on a
mille autres locaux
c'est l'autre nom
[Applaudissements]
parmi vos avez à saint leu qu'elles
touchent régulièrement des boules de
geisha aucun des deux aucun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle était pharmacienne
quand les adversaires lequel des deux a
déjà jeté des bergues s sur l'athlète de
la mairie comme assia
cieux
c'est ce qui s'est passé
histoire vraie ils ont fait coucou c'est
nous le match de l'om à chatter couscous
excuses aux as et ça c'est en 93 fois un
plateau mais c'est en héros aux libertés
moi j'avais quoi j'avais 17 ans tu vois
et je fais avec mes potes et on en bout
il y avait une brique on bastia ce que
tu veux faire tu le jettes des merguez
et et je te jure ils ont été les
missions à plus de nous quel beau
souvenir
non mais c'est superman
parmi vos adversaires
lequel des deux est secrètement
admirateur de zlatan ibrahimovic 70
parce qu'il ya un truc qui n'osent pas
avouer le psg donc il est fanatique de
l'om donc innocent il n'ose pas dire à
cause de ça et qu'ils aiment la tan
ibrahim vie qu'est ce qu'elle est fort
c'est lui
[Applaudissements]
parmi vous avez lequel des deux fait
partie du top 50 des personnalités
préférées des français
seraient ils pas bien sûr c'est sandrine
deneux jour même pas ce jour elle n'a
jamais jeté de merguez la porte qui
s'est elle bien sûr et non aucun
et bien c'est une erreur et bien c'est
une erreur parce qu'elle mériterait
d'être sur le podium parmi eux des
inserts lequel des deux a déjà défilé au
salon du chocolat en suisse entre une
forte présence des cendriers
[Musique]
le quai ce bébé appelé son fils gaston
gaston gâteau c'est joli gaston à 7
rebonds ou gaston fébus en fils sa belle
gaston votre fils oui bon c'est pas moi
qui ai pas
compris bravo
[Musique]
on a discuté
jusque là sont de 17 pour vous 22 pour
vous on continue avec le dieu au quiz
[Applaudissements]
parmi eux un adversaire lequel des deux
a déjà rencontré le général de gaulle
je dirai aucun mot je dirai aucun mot
ouais aucun aucun voisine bachelot
[Musique]
j'avais neuf
c'est pas vrai parce que je n'ai
heureusement
résistant grand résistant et donc le
général de gaulle est venu à la maison
il a dit allez où la petite quand il m'a
vu
embrasser il est web apps leurs autres
membres moi c'est dave
moins de 18 ans
ce matin ils m'embrassent ait envie de
partir
quand même adversaire lequel les deux à
passer une nuit sur la tombe du créateur
de tintin hergé
ça c'est un piège à la con tu dis que tu
dises une livre
sauf que barron meade succès habituel
mais si ce n
est pas sûr que j'ai une réponse
aucun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis arrivé ça lui arrivait à
découvert mais longtemps après qu au
moment précis où j'inventais le chat
recevoir de mars 83 hergé au moment-même
était en train de mourir dans une
clinique bruce draft il n'a pas supporté
il s'est dit je préfère mourir attention
parmi vous adversaire lequel des deux a
fait parler de lui le jour de sa
naissance dans les médias je pense que
c'est philippe mais chez plus pourquoi
moi qui lui ai mené pendant que sa mère
conduisait non c'est comme ça possibles
et imaginables
ça reste maintenant moi je dis que c'est
fait alors c'est glee philippe fils
benoît ben ouais
parce que bébé
premier bébé en belgique n'est selon la
méthode de l'accouchement dit sans
douleur exactement c'est ça et ouais tu
ma photo dans le journal
et j'étais rétrospectivement très vexé
que le journal ne titre pas naissance du
dessinateur philippe geluck
[Rires]
attention parmi vos adversaires lequel
des deux connaît la blagues cochonnes
yuki
way sur roselyne roselyne
[Musique]
basse et un monsieur qui promène son
chien dans les jardins du luxembourg il
rencontre un autre monsieur kilos vous
en avez un joli tiens oui s'appelle yuki
il se faire des tas de choses
que vous pouvez montrer ue qui donne la
papatte ue qui donne notre pape at you
qui croise les papattes ue qui suce le
monsieur ue qui suce monsieur bon yuki
je te montre mais c'est la dernière
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste juste pour rappeler aux gens
qui regardent que cette personne était
ministre de la république
parmi vous avez un cerf justement qui a
sucé le monsieur
lequel a été mise des transports
pourquoi lui qu'ont alors
[Musique]
aucun ah oui la
place et on est y résister
hormis aux adversaires lequel des deux a
pour troisième prénom marcel ça c'est
vraiment la question à de merde ouais
bien pourri c'est juste la question
demeure roselyne ouais
[Musique]
mais les adversaires lequel des deux lui
au milieu d'une douzaine de chats young
je crois que c'est aucun je crois que
c'est ok ouais ouais aucun des ricains
bravo
le cap des scores
sandrine et mathieu 23
et vous 22
attention on continue avec la quatrième
épreuve lardy quiz
alors qu'on joue en même temps
interview à ma façon vous appuyez sur le
buzzer quand vous avez la bonne réponse
ouais mais attention là on n'appuie pas
n'importe comment mais nos conflits vie
te fais
mais il ya une contrainte ya une
compacte ce soir toutes les réponses
devront se terminer en in comme roselyne
comme roselyne alors attention un point
par bonne réponse d'accord vous faire un
exemple pour qu'on soit bien d'accord
pour quelle personnalité trouble
avez-vous de l'admiration
raspoutine web ya pas mal aussi ses
rimes jacques mesrine l'héroïne de ces
merveilleux petit livre pour enfants
martin les troubles 1 elle est rouge
notamment dans ce merveilleux titre
inédit encore martin aime lapine
ça c'est hermine passé hélas ces
troubles à ces troubles c'est n'importe
quoi et yuki calme-toi hockey ou qui
sait ce qui
[Applaudissements]
j'en suis vous concentrez vous parce que
là c'est très difficile quel bruit en
ligne ne supportez vous vraiment pas win
c'est pas mal pete wentz à la rivière
saint-louis et une onomatopée philippe
katerine la musique de titres caceis et
à gauche in assez chiant ça aussi bas
exact dans quel endroit
avez-vous très souvent fait l'amour en
indochine ne t'a fait l'amour en
indochine toi c'est quoi andrew string
ça tu m'intéresses
alors je vais facebook l'indochine c'est
un endroit quand même non il n'en peut
plus il est quand même et le jour
on avait su on étendait le jour de john
gamme c6 et j'en garde un souvenir très
douloureux fait c'est pas acceptable
alors je demande à dieu
questions au fils beaucoup à mon sens
oui
j'ai vu comme ça qu'à la balle à dieu il
est super sympa je suis resté sur les
latrines sera plus pareil
on a tous dieu danse avec les stars
attention quelle moustachu célèbre en
rien refroidi
tallinn staline bonnes réponses
l'admission d'air dans le moule mais au
contraire bien staline ya régine et à
charlie chaplin quel personnage
rêveriez-vous d'incarner au cinéma à
spotted
[Applaudissements]
quelle substance aimez vous prendre pour
avoir la paix parce que la bibine
libye
[Musique]
donc quel endroit mais voyez vous pas
passé huit heures par jour chez marine à
bien
[Applaudissements]
tiens il ya aussi chez roselyne week ny
56 quel vêtement portez-vous très
régulièrement l'époque martine ouais
j'ai donc martin c'est pas un vêtement
c'est des chaussures une cabale
[Applaudissements]
honnêtement il avait aussi un dynamo de
merde quel acteur faisait rêver quand
j'étais gosse dean martin
quel traînant ne vous inspire pas trop
confiants sandrine sandrine qui sandrine
mais elle connut une chance biblique or
voilà
coup politique avez vous été très fan
matin tu attends d indochine parce que
c'est vrai
métal or on a dit que ces missions qu'on
a dit mythique et puis on a des groupes
de musique
ken quinn keane
quid
taddei calais qui favorisé tous niveaux
les besoins
[Applaudissements]
c'est éreintant mais
bruxelles après vous avez trop peu on a
25 ouais
[Applaudissements]
et voilà on termine maintenant avec la
grande finale le music quiz
[Musique]
attention chacun voit le soin entre deux
thèmes mais tout le monde joue à chaque
fois ces deux points la part de nos
réponses vous êtes pressé la grande
finale on est super pratique depuis 102
heures quand vous avez la réponse
attention roselyne je donne le choix
entre deux thèmes la santé ont été mises
la santé ou les girls band menaçons la
santé la santé en changer de prêt
bientôt réparé excusez moi il faut
donner le groupe pour le titre
l'interprète on est dans le groupe
non utilise les mots du sud david
[Musique]
fisher et ses clients de ça je vais te
le dire tout de suite
shirley bassey tu non non j'en ai trop
dit non on se lave à terme non
non non non madame
nerveux n'ont pas manqué
wen 4 1
c'est de laisser mon corps 3 go est
élucidé vaya con dios
laisse-moi les justes sur internet
peggy lee
simmons d'elivia figo
et
david
lavaux l'avait d'amour qu'il noue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans
m
enfants
le cèdre soit 100
on l'a dit exactement la griffe les
replays mes enfants ils plus en plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dieu merci beaucoup
bon alors le troisième type est
tellement facile que je vais vous lire
les paroles et vous allez me donner
l'interprète si tu te demandes comment
draguer cet été pour te conseiller je
suis ok monte sur mon podium n'est pas
peur de l'homme ni de son spéculum
doc gynéco bras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en même temps soit peu le niveau
toi que niveau va pas les centres
d'intérêts l'adversaire il a fait les
universités des jeunes ump ouais moi
j'adore j'adore c'est en tous les cas
philips annonce à vous de choisir le
deuxième thème et j'ouvre les louches à
votre créature ou les belges vos
compatriotes
les belges attention david
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hague
et après ils nous parlent du niveau
il fait
attention le vide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sommer
arnaud bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prenez tous deux auteurs
sa seule chanson consacrée à l'europe
qui est depuis le début d'une europe
mais franchement elle super attention le
troisième titre est trop facile on va
écouter une cover et j'aime donner le
nom de l'interprète original de la
chanson vous êtes prêt à tendre et david
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
porical
trente six pour vous 29 fois
[Applaudissements]
semblé à vous de choisir une troisième
thème est ce que vous voulez danse avec
les stars ou les rockeuses vu que vous
jouez dans un groupe de rock qui super
bowl en rockeuse marrante kimasi est
sûre les rockeuses s'est terminée à vous
avais perdu vingt derniers logés rentrée
comment des rockers taxi à l'émission en
série a dont ils ont gagné thierry ça va
être très très difficile attention david
dameron vous oblige à lui trouver un
lundi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon choix de catégorie au plus on arrive
à genoux n'a été inquiété dans cette
émission limite on se fait chier on voit
pas venir et tout cas pas de suspense
attention d'avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
estime t il
mamie et
non janis joplin
mercedes benz le troisième titre un peu
facile on va écouter une cover david
joan jett trafford
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
o
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la vente bien son nom cette émission
sans les connaître c'est britney spears
qui sont couverts de john
moi je pense déjà brûlé classe et de
choisir ses collaborateurs
auront vous abonner à moi je dermato
d'avis qu'elle veut dire vides je crois
que c'est grillé pour nous à moins qu'il
y ait une dernière question à 500 points
à pile ou face oui c'est ça
attention matthews avait choisir le
format algérie du ive tél est ce que
vous voulez la police vous avez fait des
études de criminologie nuit où les armes
emia luxe sont vos racines
les comment ça a merdé longtemps
unique et invasive les arméniens les
armes
[Rires]
attention à bloc on parle d'arméniens
mesdames messieurs david
elle a toujours
joui
[Applaudissements]
et
même source est nulle pour dire tu veux
dire reconnaître patrick fiori c'est un
mal qui reconnaît patrick tu sais que
même patrick fiori se reconnaît pas
lui-même c'est quoi son vrai nom c'est
chou chailland on ne peut pas dire quoi
alors fiori secor ces souches haillan en
arménien ça veut dire homme qui change
de nom pour pas que ça va maison explose
en corse c'est ça c'est pour ça qu'il a
changé il a fait ça mais c'est chiant il
s'appelle choucha l'embrasser à doha
doit on en voit c'est très bien ce qu'on
embrasse pas tous les arméniens ouais on
embrasse tous les survivants bisous à
tous moi
attention david
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
scher sarkissian fait ça exactement
david
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
l'énième
[Musique]
m
et voilà le troisième titre elle est
tellement facile que je vais vous le
passez en accéléré david
[Musique]
le feuilleton va dans ce sens mais quand
c'est là
mais il l'a reconnu au nom géré
coloniale a annoncé qu'elle s'est même
accélérée et ben voilà à l'issue de
cette grande finale il n'y a pas eu de
match qui
est de 29 ans roseline
film est de 48
[Applaudissements]
jamais non cette émission est le plus
téleghma mais personne n'a qu'a fait 40
dans le sang
ancian sandrine et mathieu je demande du
respect entre ici j'me avec ton terrible
cortège oh la la
c'est la panthéonisation
la légende il est directement au
panthéon des jeux t oui ici jean moulin
le fond sur
les prénoms à tous les deux vous
féliciter pour cette brillante victoire
vous avez été remarquable vous avez joué
ça a été un bonheur que vous affronter
ce soir mais vous avez été les plus
forts et nous sommes fiers pour vous et
pour vos familles trop fort
non non non non mais un revêtement
honnêtement vous m'avez bluffé ge et
honnêtement j'y croyais point de départ
et à l'arrivée je dois dire et je veux
dire c'est de très bon coeur que je vais
vous laisser faire votre propos et je
m'abstiendrai de faire la mienne car
telle est la règle du jeu vous allez
voir l'élégance du bonhomme plus amour
l'usa montre
et c'est le moment un petit peu
difficile de cette émission c'est quand
les perdants voit les autres faire leur
poids et c'est dur assez dur et voilà
alors d'abord évidemment
je lui dis peut-être ya des sourds muets
qui apprécient mes livres et j'essaye de
m'en parler
attention bon à propos des perdants
franchement vous inquiétez pas ça va
très vite c'est roselyne bachelot le
grand vide sur des 8es vous pouvez écire
europe et sur l'europe les pieds dans
les albums j'appelle le chat je crois
c'est ça ben oui on n'est pas là pour ça
va vérifier les pneus de ta bagnole quoi
la sortie du
nom sandrine et mathieu c'est le bonheur
sandrine oui vous êtes le rayon de
soleil de tenir si terry gou battait des
records d'audience toutes les semaines
avec cinq ans
et depuis que la nouvelle formule ça
marche encore mieux et franchement ça ne
me fait rien d'être battu par bus toutes
les semaines il sait gérer ce que je
vous adore vous invite à découvrir une
autre facette du talent de sandrine sur
la chaîne stylia avec son émission a
vite tendance se passe du à castres et
un tiers il ya aussi la tournée danse
avec les stars sur les routes de france
jusqu'à la fin du mois de février où on
donne des spectacles dans tous les
zénith à la une trentaine de dates on
retrouve sur le site danse avec les
stars la tournée et on est ravi afrique
si 7000 personnes qui viennent nous
applaudir avec les personnalités de
cette saison et des saisons précédentes
et on s'amuse beaucoup également les
tirages du loto
de 40
voilà une idée
jeter ça va compliquer quand vous
allumez rtl et surtout
merci vous en plus fort mais
alors la
la virée vous savez l'estimé et l'amitié
que j'ai pour vous m'ayant côté de funès
comme ça avec les gagnants on faisait
que tony
parker
fait tous les dimanches de sauter carpet
me disent inspirés de truqueur mathieu j
-c coutoisie mathieu ces sables depuis
laurent baffie je n'ai pas vu quelqu'un
balancé aux jambes bonne vanne sur un
plateau chaque fois que vous venez dans
l'une de mes émissions où le fait
beaucoup rire je vous adore vous savez
que vous savez ça fait plaisir je rêve
de vous produire je sens vrai talent
faut aller voir mathieu sur scène c'est
très important bon moment j'envoie le
plan jean séverin jamais été déçu sur
elle c'est la mériter dans les heures
les plus grandes scènes de france sont
allés voir mathieu aux chaînés aviles
pape s'est à chaque fois
c'est bien c'est elle une vraie bonne
promo même
non pas gagner parce qu'on avait été
totalement ridicule philippe on a eu
raison de délaisser gars qui je pense
sera connu
non mais c'est souvent mais c'est quand
le perdant est beau joueur c'est lui qui
ramasse la mise oui c'est le chat pas ce
talent qui s'éteint 16,17 euros cas par
cas
j'espère que vous aurez passé
roselyne bachelot
charpy
[Musique]
danse avec les stars soirée
qu'ils sortent toutes les deux mieux
lazio mabillon
il met lui a plu à cette émission et
n'oubliez pas
[Applaudissements]
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu